right alright the most amazing list on
your right hot pan olive oil
stay with me boy yeah yes or Little Boy
slim boy olive all in yes now and Harris
in first okay good carrots in now onion
in you're not just regretted two-thirds
of Goregaon Oh in season it usefully yes
now Johnny yeah you often make lasagna I
do but I don't make it like this on the
black eye I take a full day what onion
terracing great your Bartlett's into the
garbage Johnny right okay change your
visa in Cambridge
Lisa encourage yes are you doing better
on the main course he did with the start
because that looked like vomit now do me
a quick favor yes before you only father
will you show me and point out the
emergency exits in your kitchen
Samuel right garlic carrots in there
keep that pan really hot no time for the
mince in now if you keep it nice and
flat in the pan it cooks a lot quicker
and more importantly it stops the meat
from boiling so onions carrots Bailey's
garlic boils
the secret now is put a really good
color on the mints
the idea is getting a really nice rich
dark savory meat source of lettuce and